[拍手]
皆さんお昼ご飯はもう食べられますでしょうか
今はですね1時半ぐらいなんで皆さんこの割り箸使って食べたかっていっぱい
いらっしゃるんじゃないかなと思うんですけどもみなさんですね
全部残さずにきちんと食べられますでしょうか
場所ですね全部食べたかったんですけどドームですねこの最後に一割バスだけは食べれ
なかったんですよ
ちょっと腹ペタをありがとうございます
そぼーるもあるのはどうもありがとうございますみなさんは終わり走って食べられない
じゃないかと
を与え旨じゃないかとそういうふうに思ってませんか
何でもあり走って食べられないか分かります
皆さんですねどうやって割り箸がつかれているかご存知ですか
割り箸っていうのは
木をですね温めて棒状に成形して作ったものが終わりますなんですよ
平たく簡単に言いますと植物をすごくあっためて棒状にしたと
このですねこれと何が違うでしょうか
僕をチェックを好きなんですよ皆さんたいと思いますフラットドって言うんですけど僕
これめっちゃ好きなんですよ
でもじゃがいもだから食べれるとこれは食べられて
木場食べられないどっちも植物のにこんだけ違いがあるんですよ
何でかって考えたことありますか
割り箸は期だから食べられないと皆さんご存知の通りでございますそれは正しい知識な
んですけども
僕たちだってですね野菜を食べるわけですよニンジンとか大根だって硬い毛を食べれ
ますよね
けど冷え食べたことあるぞそんなにないと思う
僕もそんなにないですキー食べたこと1回ぐらいもありますけれども
僕はですねこれについてちょっと考えてみたいなと思ったんです
高校の時にお弁当を食べていて最後に割れました残ったんです
なんでこれ食べられないんだろうと
私は思います
理科の先生にですね聞いてみたら割り箸っていうのは
きっていうのはセルロースっていうものを主成分に持っていると
これはとっても固いから食べることができないんだと
いうふうに教えていただきます
の僕は思ってしまったわけですよ本当にと僕らて野菜は食べるぞ内閣
けど気が食べられないということにとても疑問を感じます
僕はその時の衝動も富ですね今研究をしています
なの研究をしているんですかと聞かれますと私は一番良いですね自信満々にこういます
割り箸を食べる研究をしてくると
本当はですねセルロース分解の研究をしているんですけどもまぁ完全に分化できるよう
になればそれはですね
食べることとほとんど同じなのでまあいいかなと思ってそういうふうに言っています
実際セルロースの分解て得られる党っていうのはいろんな研究の派生がありまして年で
降りようとかそういうのも期待されています
もしかしたら燃料量がすごくすごく進めばですね皆さんが帰りにですねバイクに今日
もらったプリントもいらんだと思った彼突っ込んで買って帰るんでそういう未来がもし
かしたらあるかもしれません
ちょっとですね話が変わるんですけども僕がこの割バスの疑問も都度けど同じ年頃の子
たちに話をする近いがこの前あります
この春にはたちは教育実習に行ってきたんですけど教育優秀でですね
初めに自己紹介をしますその時に僕にパッと言ってきた女の子もいます
セ d カンを先生なんですか私は陸が一番嫌いだと
若干ショックだったんですけど
た芝ですねどうにかして生徒技ですね時間の興味を持ってくれないのかなというふうに
思ったんですよ
そこで私は最後に時間を授業の終わりにちょっと頭ですね時間の疑問の話っていうもの
をしていきますと日常寝転がって科学の話をしてそしてこそ言わずに置いておいたん
です
すると生徒の方から僕の方に気に入ってくれるんですよ
先生コレってどうなんですか
ボクはけっとこれはこうだと思うんですよ
とっても感動しますちょっとしっかりとか疑問があるだけで
私にですねこんなに消えてくれるんだこんなに興味を持ってくれるんだと
最後の日にですね初めに僕に陸が好きじゃないと言ってきてきた公がちょっと理科が
好きなというふうに伝えてくれます
最近の一番の思い出です
今日はちょっとそんな話を皆さんにもしたいなぁと思いまして
日常ですね時間の不思議の話をちょっと紹介したいと思います
皆さんは日常に疑問を感じることはありますか
当たり前だからと思ってスルーしてることで実はたくさんあるんじゃないかなという
ふうにたちは思います
よかったらちょっと例えばですね一つ目皆さん水って知ってます
知ってますよね水が沸騰する温度って何度かわかりますか
百度多分頭に思い浮かべて構ったらいっぱいいると思います
水は100度で沸騰して蒸発して水蒸気になりますこれは探し一式です
小学校で習います
けどここで考えてみたことがあります
戦術雨が降った時に僕の通学路に水たまりがたくさんありました
でも今日来るときはもなかったんですよ
あれどこ行ったんですよね
かわいいだと思われ方それって蒸発してるんですよじゃああの水玉れて100で行った
んですよ
ん
ちょっと考えてみたら面白そうな気がしませんか
じゃあ例えば次にですね皆さんゲージ見たことありますか
僕ないんですよカークやってにもかかわらず限知ってその日常的に見ないでも皆さんが
座ったリストか僕が持っている木も金とか服とか全部原子ができているんです
聞いとか体はすべて原子からできています
じゃあ見えてるんじゃないかと
皆さん空気見えますか
空気って原子からできてるんですよ空気も原子ができるんですよ
この僕たちが生きている世界というのは見えない件知ってもので構成されている
見えている世界なんですよしかもその中でねーな妹見えるものがはっきりと区別されて
いるそんな世界なんですよ
そういう世界にロマンって何か感じたりしないでしょうか
最後月有名な話になりますが鉛筆の芯と会場で付けてる方いらっしゃいますね
ダイヤモンドっていうのは同じ炭素化できています
姿形は全然違いますが構成要素はどっちも炭素って全く同じ物質です
身の回りにもう一つ
同じものからできてるものがありますがちょっと考えてみて何かこれとこれをなでも
できてるんじゃないか見たいものってありますか
答えを言いましょうそれはですねデンプンとセルロースです
平たく言いますとみなさんが普段食べている
パンとかご飯とかジャガイモとかそういうデンプンとキー p
ものは同じものからできてるんですよどっちも
グルコースという構成要素を持っています
どちらもですねこれがつながって繋がってつながってできているんですよ
会で書くとでんぷんっていうのはこんな感じでセルロースはですね体が上下した構造を
とっています
でもたったこれだけなんですよ構成要素は全くので撮ってのグルコースです
ミクロの目線で見て科学の目線で見て
こんだけの違いしかなのに僕立つのですね目に入る時にはもう随分と違うものになって
いる
そういうことって科学の世界では普通にありえるんです
氷山の一角という言葉がありますが
これはですね見えている小さい部分よりも大きな見えない部分があることのたとえとし
て使われます
僕はですねこれは真理であると思っています
皆さんのですね目に見えている世界の出来事っていうのはきっとですね見えていない
大きなバックグラウンドを持っています
道端にですね生えてる花猫ってどうなってるかわからないじゃないですか
そこらに生えてる小さい臭いさえももしかしたら地下ではすごく大きな実をつけている
かもしれない
僕たちがですねダーツの日常歩いていて踏みつけて
さあとですね見えない部分っていうのはもしかしたらとても大きな大事なことなのかも
しれない
僕はですねこのキッカケっていうものを見つけるきっかけから掘ってみるということを
科学と呼ぶのだと思います
皆さんが出た日常に感じる不思議っていうのはきっと氷山の一角です
なぜっていうことを考えることから科学は始まります
ニュートンはリンゴが木から落ちるのを見てなぜだと思ったと言われています
彼の私は高校生の時に割り箸がですね食べられないことですね
気が食べられないということをなぜだというふうに思います
僕はニュートンみたいにだな人物ではありませんしかし
考えることができますそれは僕だけじゃなくてあなたがたにも絶対に可能です
もう腰かしたらですね僕たちよりも僕よりもきっとですね素晴らしい発想するとが
たくさんいらっしゃると思います
しっかしからですねとも何かは始まるんです別に研究ができなくても構わないんです
きっかけを見つけて進んだ誰かになることがとても大事なことでもしかしたらここに
いる誰か
私も含めて皆さんも含めて
未来のノーベル賞につながるようなそんなですねきっかけを見つける誰かままかもしれ
ません
私の人生は中学生の時に高校生の時にですね
セルロースはリバストであって少しながら変わります
日常寝転がってる二ティガですねあなたがたの人生を変えていくかもしれません
日常の不思議っていうのはあなたがたの人生を変えます
理科的な話だけではなくて今後ですね自分の進路を決める
何か選択肢を選ぶときに自分の気持ちが一番大事です
とても大事なのだと思いますでもじゃあその気持ちをつくってもなにか考えてみて
くださいそれはキュッと日常の出来事です
日常の出来事不思議っていうのは今と未来の自分の気持ちとこれからも前世を変えると
いう大きな力を持っています
じゃあどうやってその力を感じればいいのか
とっても簡単ですそれは興味を持つことだけです
すべてのものにですね興味を持つのはとっても難しいことです
そして知識も必要になるかもしれませんけど知識なんて後から部の勉強することができ
ます
日常の瞬間て次ツイートですね早く流れ去っていってしまうんですよ僕たちの税制の中
でメール見れば今日チェックするイベントなんてそんな一瞬です本当にすぐです
興味を持つないと見逃し済むことたくさんあります
全部に興味を持つのは難しくても無関心じゃないって言うことだけは
キッズですね心のもちを一つだと私はそういうふうに思います
皆さんがですね今一番不思議に思う事ってなんでしょうか
一番ですね興味を持っていることって何でしょうか
きっとそれは後の人生を変える
とても大きな力を秘めています
興味を持つことからカーフがきっと始まりますぜひですね皆さんのですね日常
そして人生を科学して見ていただけたらなと思いますどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]